je préfère son père ou sa mère
ça c'est un piège à rat s'est pas fait
tu peux pas répondre tu peux être moi
non je suis incapable de répondre oui
d'émission sur traumat elisor des
questions aux comptes
si vous passez pour kick le plus au fait
à qui tu pouvais plus de circonstances
atténuantes
ja rule skis ou à pinochet aucun avocat
n'est en aucun cas des circonstances
atténuantes porteurs de voir des gens
dangereux
chose de terrifiant je pense qu'ils sont
aussi pierre l'emploi
oui aussi grave question compte c'est
plus facile maintenant si tu devais
partir sur une île déserte
tu peux faire repartir avec jospin ou
juppé sinon oui bon tir dès qu'un malawi
ah bon peut-être parce qu'ils étaient
socialistes parce qu'il est mieux équipé
il est peut-être donc en vous parlant
les politiques le derby tendu par
imagine maintenant c'est la guerre une
espionne été arrêtés ont dit voilà on va
la voile a tué à ce que vaut pas le
droit d'être espion est ce que tu
préfères être fusillé guillotine et ça
aussi c'est très con parce que coûte
la chaise électrique non pas au nom de
quoi non j'avais crié peut-être alors
avant fusillait pourquoi tu penses que
c'est la dante latentes sur l'europe ou
face au recul attendu la zone
caractérise c'est pas pareil
là on vit en position est-ce que magie
n'ont toujours pas si on me disait voilà
vous rester paralysé toute votre vie
allongé sur un lit en fer en fait à
faire mais il y aura plus jamais
d'inondations bengladesh ou les
petits-enfants du bangladesh pourront
manger du riz à leur faim jusqu'à la fin
des temps sacrifie ma peignant oui non
je crois pas que j'ai réagi ce qu elle
sacrifier même même si en face du manège
trouver vue auprès des allemands
geoffrey après tout moore dans la
réalité tu feras pas que dernière
question maintenant parce qu'une façon
la bombe harry est ce que c'est la paix
comme ça c'est pas la violence et
imagine que voilà un jour tu allumes la
radio en attelage je travaille à la
radio jeudi une bombe atomique est parti
de quelque part dans une fusée et puis
la bombe arrive dans cinq minutes
qu'est-ce que tu le sais pas quelles
sont les dernières choses que tu t'es la
mère parfaite en verre tu t'en vois en
l'air qu'est ce que tu crois que la
dernière solution à la guerre